hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast stressed out the
consequences of environmentally induced
stress on mouse models presented by
Brianna Gaskell PhD we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots to learn more
about lab roots please visit www I'm
Judy O'Rourke elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
race continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your CD
credits click on the CD button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you're viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce Brianna gassville PhD
assistant professor of animal welfare in
the College of Veterinary Medicine and
part of the Center for animal welfare
science at Purdue University dr. gaskill
received a PhD in animal behavior on
well-being from Purdue she worked as a
postdoctoral research scientist at
Charles River studying the behavior and
well-being of laboratory rodents dr.
Gaskell's research program focuses on
welfare assessment of laboratory animals
she uses natural behavior psychology and
effective state to assess an animal's
overall well-being dr. gaskill is
especially interested in discovering how
better welfare can translate into better
and more robust science dr. gaskill has
been involved in developing new and
improved
types of cognitive testing from lights
that are used in psychiatric and
neuroscience research and has published
in behavior and well-being laboratory
animal and experimental psychology
literature's her complete bio is on the
labyrinth site please join me in
welcoming dr. Brianna Gaskell I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you Judy I want to say thank you to
everyone who is listening in on this
presentation because it's obviously
something I find very important and
something that I think we don't
necessarily always talk enough about so
I'm hoping that you'll get at least some
information hopefully some ideas to take
away from this presentation at the end
and I'm really looking forward to any
questions that you all have at the end
as well so we'll go ahead and get
started but before we really get into
too much of the nitty gritty details I
want to start off with a bit of a story
so I want to introduce you to hans selye
a I think I'm pronouncing that right who
is really the the father of stress
physiology and just to kind of give you
an idea of how stumbled across the
stress response in the 1930s he was a
young budding scientist and you know
trying to look at how hormones affected
the body and so he was actually
beginning to study an extract that came
from an ovary and he was starting to
give some wraps that he was utilizing
daily injections of this extract and
let's just say that Hans probably didn't
take the I cook training course on how
to properly give injections to rats
because as the story goes he was not
very well practiced and sometimes
dropped the rats sometimes they wiggled
away he chased them around the room and
so therefore you had a very difficult
time actually giving these daily
injections you might think that after
several months of doing this we might
get better but later on when he was
assessing what type of changes
we're having were occurring in these
rats based on his extract he found that
many of the rats had ulcers they had
enlarged adrenal glands and shrunken
immune tissues and so he was like oh
this is great I found out what this
extract potentially does the body but as
a good scientist he went back and he did
the same thing looking at just injecting
the rats of saline lo and behold he
found out that they had the exact same
results and physiological changes and he
more or less reason doubt that it was
probably his poor injection procedures
that was potentially causing this this
reaction in these animals and that they
had a nonspecific response to some kind
of unpleasantness and so as he went on
he he was like all right I want to look
into this a little bit further so what
he did is he again probably not
something that would go through our I
cook today but he put wraps on the roof
of the building in the middle of winter
he put rats in a boiler room forced them
into exercise as well as per sub did
surgical procedures on these animals and
he came to find out that they had all of
the same physiological response even
though the environment they're in was
quite different and so really at this
point he had discovered the beginning of
stress stress related disease and so he
was trying to figure out how what to
call this and actually borrowed a term
some physics and ultimately came up with
the word stress and how to describe his
physiological non non specific responses
to some type of unpleasant so we called
it stress and really he formulated this
idea that received the exact same
response to a broad array of stressors
and that if they happen for too long
people in animals get sick and so not
only that but he terms and identified
that stress can be good and stress can
be bad so stress in general is any
alteration to homeostasis and that
there's a difference between
really the outcome and making stress
good stress or bad stress so distress is
an alteration that cannot be corrected
without compromising an alternative
biological system so for instance this
might be malnutrition affecting
reproduction rates but you stress is an
alteration that ultimately leads to
behavioral and physiological
developments and animals or humans
ability to better cope with future
challenges so really it's the way that
the end goal so when you think about an
example of this is exercise so we stress
our body through exercise but to
eventually get better and stronger as
you progress in your workouts so why am
I telling me the story besides just
giving you some background as to where
stress physiology came from well if you
think about it the way that sellier
stumbled upon the stress pathway is
through the way that he was working with
his laboratory animals and especially in
a way that is not necessarily good for
them and was stressful so I'd like you
to think about you know where we would
be if he hadn't accidentally been
untrained in giving his injections and
some way across this nonspecific
response to unpleasantness and where we
might be today and think about it in
terms of the research that we're doing
now and how the things the ways that
we're handling animals the environments
were putting them in may be causing some
types of stress so moving into the main
part of this talk so environmental
stressors especially when you're
thinking about them in terms for rodents
in particular there's lots of things
that can lead to stress so for instance
the lack of retreat space is seen as a
high predation risk which I'm attempting
to illustrate with this image on the
right of a an undergraduate student
working in my lab and so the animals
don't have the
we need to hide and so their prey
species and this is a very high drive
for them because it means survival and
so if they don't have a retreat space
this is stressful because they aren't be
able to hide from the Predators that
they perceive us to be even if we're not
necessarily going to eat them so there's
no ability to aid in thermoregulation
quite often because there's no place for
them to huddle in and especially if
we're utilizing and ventilated caging
there's no ability to shelter from
drafts which is actually something
rodents are afraid of because it's that
last stimulus right before you're picked
up by a bird of prey so puffs of air
actually very aversive to rodents
physical when I say physical I mean
physical facilities so this could be
background noise or ultrasounds that's
being given off by various things like
actually your computer screens or
ventilation systems or even water
faucets or even the jingling of your
keys actually gives off a lot of
ultrasounds and then just thinking of
just general lighting and the fact that
rodents are nocturnal and find bright
open avert a bright open space is very
aversive and yet we don't necessarily
Taylor any of the lighting to these
animals needs but you can also have
social stressors so you have odor and
auditory cues from other cages or
animals cage cleaning one of the
absolute things that we have to do in
order to keep these animals healthy
actually disrupts urine marking and
communication as well as being a
stressful act and I'll illustrate this a
little bit further and then lastly
temperature is actually a really big
stressor specifically for mice in
particular and that they're actually
cold stress in the laboratory and we'll
get into that in each of these and a
little bit more detail as we go along so
if we're not allowed to alleviate these
stressors they lead to chronic
uncontrollable stress and we start
seeing those non specific responses to
unpleasantness or the beginnings of
potentially stress related disease that
sellier found so all of these this uncle
total stress can really alter autonomic
function or endocrine function and
really immune responses and can lead to
the development of abnormal behaviors
which is a welfare concern but is also a
science concern in the fact that a lot
of different animals with these abnormal
behaviors have altered brain development
and possibly poor models especially
depending on what you're utilizing this
particular model for ultimately it's an
indicator of poor welfare and this poor
little guy here in the image that I'm
showing you his mother has plucked him
to black 6 mouse and his mother is
barbered him almost completely nude and
so this is obviously very extreme
example of an adorable behavior but
obviously this particular animal is not
going to be a really great model for
some type of metabolic study because
they're you they're losing so much heat
due to not having for cover all right so
let's go through each of these
environmental stressors you know I I
definitely want to put out that this
presentation is not completely inclusive
of all the environmental stressors these
are just some that I felt like we're
good to to focus on so there's lots of
other environmental stressors but these
are the ones that I thought were perhaps
some of the most important to address in
the beginning so let's look at start
looking at retreat space what does that
how does that potentially cause stress
so actually a retreat space can be good
or bad depending on what is actually
provided so for instance the nest boxes
and shelters are actually preferred by
rats but can lead to increase stress
hormone levels in mice and actually
nesting material in mice has been the
only thing or the transfer of nesting
material has been the only thing to
actually show a reduction in male
aggression over just complete basic cage
change no scent transfer that sort of
thing so it's really the only thing
that's been shown to reduce male
aggression and that rats should appear
to be more fearful and show less
exploratory behaviors than those that
have hiding spaces so we see a lot of
behave
neural response changes when animals
don't have a retreat space and so this
is a study that was done by Howerton at
all in 2003 and they did a great job of
looking at how introducing a physical
shelter in a mouse cage changes
aggression now just any kind of
aggression they looked at escalated
aggression so really there's two types
of aggression and as you'll find in my
talk there's never a black-and-white
answer with a lot of these things it's
usually gray so actually there's good
aggression and that's actually called
mediated aggression and that really
helps establish dominance hierarchies
and so that's the type of aggression you
want to see because that means that
those animals realize who's the boss in
the cage and it's very stable but
escalated aggression is when animals are
not necessarily giving the right choose
there's days stabilization of the
dominance hierarchy and this leads to
the rough-and-tumble fighting that you
might often see in your mouse cages and
usually is the type of aggression that
leads to injury now how did in all what
they did is they compared baseline which
is the white bar levels of escalated
aggression and then compared it
afterwards they had placed this igloo
with the wheel that's in the picture on
the right in the cages and in the middle
section where it says fixed wheel
basically what the news they just glued
the wheel so it wouldn't move and then
the right set of bars is where they are
allowing the wheel to move and the mice
could run on it and what they found was
really regardless of whether the wheel
was movable or not if you place this
igloo into the cage it significantly
increased that rough and tumble in juras
escalated aggression and that's
obviously something that a lot of people
had a difficulty with in their rona
colonies is that we already see enough
aggression because these animals are
very territorial and they like to set up
territories around physical structures
so basically you just put a an
aggression time bomb in your animal
cages specifically in male male mouse
cages and so as you have
more of this escalated aggression you
subsequently have destabilization of the
hierarchy within the cage so on the x
axis we have escalated aggression as
percent of activity and so as the
escalation increases as you go to the
right side you see that the dominance
hierarchy decreases so it's becoming
more and more destabilized and as you
have more and more destabilization you
actually it can potentially induce
immune suppression as well so this was a
fabulous study done by Barnard at all in
96 and on the graph on the right that's
looking at just some antibodies to a
particular pathogen that these animals
were challenged with and you see that as
the number of attacks the animal
received increases you see a reduction
in those antibodies in those animals and
subsequently similar to the graph on the
right as the number of attacks increase
so as we go closer to the 16 they had a
longer time to clear that parasite than
animals that received fewer fewer
attacks so this can have a huge impact
on the research that you might be
utilizing or utilizing these animals
board so thinking about again the
inability to shelter from drafts so
ventilated caging is almost ubiquitous
lead used nowadays and animal facilities
and I've always been kind of surprised
that people utilize him as much because
because anna mice absolutely hate being
in a wind tunnel and this was actually
very well illustrated by Baumann and all
in 2002 and basically what they did we
they had two cages that were linked
together so in the image in the top
where it has where it says 4a and 4b
they had these two ventilated cages that
were hooked together so the mouse could
go back and forth and choose where he
wanted to spend his time now they went
through various studies comparing
different ventilation rates and
ultimately what they found was
that there was an overall high avoidance
of ventilation of the ventilated cages
when there was no nesting material
animals purposely avoided it almost
complete me when they had option but the
thing that was really kind of cool is
that in another set of these studies
they did the same comparisons of
ventilation rates in a and B and vice
versa but they provided the mice with
nesting material and what they found is
that the mice in really care as much
about the ventilation rates when they
were able to shelter in a nest so not
only is it important that you give them
a type of shelter but it also depends on
the kind of shelter so that's what the
graph that I'm showing you on this
particular slide so on the x-axis 123 is
actually the days of a preference test
so again we've got our two cages that
are linked together and we're looking to
see where than my spend their time now
in these two cages they have the exact
same ventilation rate the only
difference is that in the kind of grade
in area cage a they provided them with
an S box and if you're remembering
already said that nest boxes really
aren't as preferred by mice as rats and
in the white section of the bars is the
cage be where they were provided with
nesting material a Kleenex and you can
see that on days 1 into the mice very
overwhelmingly spent more time in the
nest spot in the cages the ventilated
cages where a nesting material was but
when the nesting material was taken away
on day 3 we see that their show equal
time being spent in both of those
locations even though technically a
shelter is being provided in that great
in section cage a the animals didn't see
that as enough of a shelter to really
affect they were perceiving the two
cages as equal so really the nest box
didn't provide them with the shelter
that they really needed so this is a
really great study if you're interested
in looking it up it's it's a really nice
bit of behavioral work looking at what
did the animals actually want okay so
moving on to our next little section
here we're going to look at physical
facilities so background noise and
potentially lighting how those might
cause stress so with noise this is
something that I've been doing a little
bit more research on and I've found it
really quite surprising that the guide
has no recommended range of noise levels
in their recommendations which is really
kind of surprising to me because
ventilation equipment and rodent
facilities can get up to 110 decibels
well if you're not super familiar with
what is 110 decibels let me give you a
kind of a range of noises here so a
whisper is right around 30 decibels a
vacuum cleaner is 70 decibels a chainsaw
is right around 100 decibels and a rock
concert is at about 125 decimals so
ventilation equipment itself can get
really really high and not too much over
125 decibels you start to have issues
with hearing damage in humans and there
have been some researchers that have
been finding that their their mouse
models for hearing research they were
going deaf much faster than they were
expecting and they found that due to
some of the noise that's occurring in
these vivariums that this is habit this
is damaging the animals that they're
doing your science with even so extreme
noise over 85 decibels so this is this
is closer to a vacuum cleaner type level
of noise you start to see increases in
corticosterone levels are altered
diurnal variation in corticosterone
reduced fertility increased infection
increased incidence of tumors as well as
increases in fear behavior so noise
levels itself something that is not even
recommended by the guide is having a lot
of stress on our animals and can really
affect them in many ways not only just
hear loss but just stress and so when
we're thinking about
those results that sellier found those
are having a lot of physiological
alterations in those animals if it's a
prolonged stressor you start to see the
beginnings of the stress related disease
in those animals so the other thing I'd
like to mention is talking about
ultrasound so we can hear certain ranges
of frequencies of sound and so I've got
this image here and it's got in black
the line shows the frequencies on the
x-axis that tumors can hear with the the
best frequencies that humans can hear
being down there in the trough of that
you shape and you can see transposon top
of it is the same kind of graph of
frequencies that my skin here and you
can see the blue den section is really
where the animals do most of their vocal
communication and so it's it's ten
frequency of about 10 kilohertz and
higher and so a lot of the ultrasound
that's being given off and our
environments are vivariums is something
that we can't actually hear and so it
can be emitted by computers water taps
actually I've heard some instances of
people putting in motion sensors that
turn out not necessarily lighting but
might be in the hallways those actually
utilize ultrasound and so it's like
having an air horn constantly going off
in your facility so hopefully nobody is
really looking into utilizing any type
of motion detectors and especially
making sure that maybe if they are if
you do need to use these they are not
utilizing ultrasound for this detection
and so also ultimately you've got all
this noise going on that we as humans
don't perceive at all but these noises
can really disrupt calls from pups
because those occur in the ultrasounds
as well sexual communication as a fun
little tidbit a male mice actually sing
to females at before copulation and so
it actually sounds very close to
birdsong and so it's this can easily be
disrupted if you have a lot of other
ultrasonic noise occurring in your
facilities so to just give you some
examples of some daytime noise
variability we've got two rooms here's
the room one is labeled as a Reuters
labeled as B and room one is considered
a very high traffic by variant there
it's used by multiple pies there's
technicians in there frequently
throughout the day and as you can see in
this image so I've kind of highlighted
85 decibels of 200 so remember I said at
85 greater than 85 decibels we start to
see these stressful responses by by
rodents and you can see in the very high
traffic vivarium there is a lot a lot of
sounds in these upper decibels
especially when a cage change station
has been is being utilized and so if
this happens all day long throughout as
you can see it's from 830 a.m. until
four-thirty p.m. this is constant spikes
of these really high decibel sounds and
just as an added tidbit if we think
about it mice are nocturnal so they're
supposed to be sleeping during the day
when we're in their active do you think
that you could sleep pretty soundly if
you had all of this noise going on in
your bedroom so it has the potential to
alter sleep in these animals as well
with a lot of these high style and
decibel levels going on throughout the
day and then looking at a much more
quiet room where there's very little
activity there's only one p I you can
see that there are spikes up above 85
but it's much more infrequent across the
day and then this is just another
example of two different days of
ultrasound variability that even in the
same rooms you can have quite a bit of
difference in sound even if it is still
high traffic versus low traffic
you can still see that there's a lot of
just general sound variability occurring
in those locations so moving on to our
next area of stress light again this is
something that we don't really think
about very often and really lab lighting
conditions are are really tailored to
human means it doesn't actually
artificial lighting or fluorescent
lighting doesn't actually reflect
natural lights and having a full
spectrum of types of light it can cause
disruptions and sleep and circadian
cycles in mice you start to see
increases in plasma corticosterone
levels you see increased initiation of
fights and the biggest thing for me is
that it lacks ultraviolet light so
rodents can actually see markings at
four in the MV so I've got this little
color bar thing down on the bottom that
shows that you know my seed from the the
green blue range up into the ultraviolet
where humans can't see that upper range
and that mice can't see the red which is
kind of a fairly common factor known
about animals but not only that the so
we were talking a little bit about
aggression and scent marking actually
what I've got an image here on the right
is actually an image of a dominant mouse
that has just been confronted it is
territory and a mouse that has lost a
fight and is subordinate and you can see
the huge difference and spent marking
patterns between the dominant animal on
the left and the subordinate animal on
the right so the subordinate animal on
the right is pooling its urine in the
corners as far away as it can whereas
the dominant animal is attempting to set
mark around the perimeter and lots of
small little scent marks and so they can
actually see in the UV where the scent
marks actually fluoresce and so without
providing them with that type of light
to see these markings are we potentially
taking away one of the cues that they
utilize in order
to communicate with one another this is
my territory stay away or sorry buddy
I'm trying to just stay away as much as
I can I'm just going to go over here so
just thinking about it it's like taking
certain words out of a conversation can
you still understand the meeting and we
don't know we have no idea what what
type of information they are collecting
from being able to see in the UV so kind
of a new trend happening in laboratory
animal science is potentially looking at
utilizing different colored caging so
there's been some really great work done
by dau chi at all and looking at how
light changes as it's filtered through
different colored caging so in this
particular example doubts you looked at
clear caging and red caging and you
looked at what the spectral
transmittance is through those cages and
so in the graphs are it's a little fuzzy
you can see the clear cage and the the
type of light wavelengths that are
measured inside the cage in the black
line and you can see that there's Peaks
around for 25 475 right around 5 15 and
then around 600 and so 400 to 500 are
right around that green blue area that
you see right here and it was really the
the best vision that mice have is right
around a color vision is right around
the green blue area and so you can see
that when you filter it through a red
caging so 600 to 700 is right around
some of those red red light it doesn't
filter anything in those wavelengths but
it really affects the 400 to 550
wavelength so the main types of color
that my see well is this a good thing or
bad thing we're not really sure but we
do know that it does affect it does
affect their physiology so this is a lot
of really cool work that couch is done
looking at housing animals and clear
versus red caging and so that's depict
black is the clear caging and red is the
red lines on his graphs on the right and
what he's found is that he's seen a lot
of hormonal changes he's seen
corticosterone insulin glucose lactate
leptin hormonal changes when these
animals are just housed in these
different colored environments and in
these graphs I've just showed you two of
them the top one is plasma
corticosterone and so the interesting
thing here is that you see a blunting of
that circadian rhythm you don't see
those spikes but the question that I
might propose is what is normal should
animals and a normal state in an
environment where they prefer to be do
you still see those spikes or not
entirely sure all we know is that clear
caging you some spikes of these hormones
throughout the day and a much more
gradual circadian rhythm I'm more
blunted circadian rhythm when they're in
these colored cages any houses found
changes in and behavior and some
colleagues of mine had recently done
some preference studies looking at rats
in particular looking at a preference of
rats for different colored areas of a
cage so they gave them the option of
clear or red or looking at their
behavior that way and they found that
overall rats do prefer red caging over
clear but the question becomes one of
the issues associated with that is that
red red caging also read tinting also
reduces the intensity of light as well
as the color of light so we're not
really sure if they're choosing it just
because it's darker or if they're
choosing it because of this unique this
unique makeup of light so then it
becomes a question well what about
encaged colored shelters obviously we're
utilizing the red tinting because as I
showed you a little earlier mice and
rats don't see very well in the red
spectrum and so they seek perceive this
as being opaque but yet we can still
observe them so it's a really great
trick of utilizing this animals
specifics to our advantage but the
question becomes is this potentially
changing our animal models and we're not
entirely sure the fact that the animals
can go in and out maybe that doesn't
affect them as much because they're in
the clear cage with the red shelter but
we just don't know so talking a little
bit more about light intensity as i
measured i mentioned rodents are
nocturnal and they find these really
bright open spaces really really
aversive and actually we know this this
is the basis of a lot of anxiety tests
in that the light dark box and that we
know that they're going to try and stay
in that dark area because they find the
light open area immersive well they find
it adversely when the predator comes out
and swoops down and takes you away and
we know that they have overall
preferences for these low light
environments and yet we house them in
these very bright clear caging so that
we can observe them when we want to and
we do know that and this is I've heard
that this is up for debate but albinos
are more likely to develop I lesions
especially when they're up at the upper
levels of caging when they're really
close to that intense light exposure to
bright lighting during s adolescents
makes rats potentially more aggressive
in location in the room this is a huge
variable mice high on the rack it's a
lot brighter and we see that they have
greater emotionality and in one
particular really interesting study they
sell delayed onset of diabetes mellitus
which is a type 1 diabetes which is an
immune an autoimmune response of the
body attacking those cells and so if the
animals are stressed because they're at
the top of the cage and they've gotten
reduced immune systems they don't they
can't amount that auto auto immune
response to start attacking those cells
so because there's a delayed response
that's actually bad and potentially an
indicator of some type of stress
being that high on the rack now this
particular study didn't necessarily test
that it was light in particular come to
find out that for a fluorescent lighting
also gives off ultrasound so it could be
a combination of those two things but
they didn't directly test that but they
did find that those animals at the top
of the rack did have delayed onset so
just to give you an idea of lighting
conditions I went into a facility and
measured some light intensity or looks
in different cages as I've got
illustrated here in this image so i put
i measured at the very top through the
plastic bubble in section a a cage at
the bottom of that isolator on that top
isolator which is section b and then
measure the the lighting attention e @ c
and d and that bottom isolator and you
can see that the brunt and this is in
the cage underneath food and a water
bottle so you still see that that does
provide a small a bit of shade for these
animals or reduces the light intensity
and the room where that guy is standing
it was actually 328 looks and i believe
the guide recommends i think it's less
than it's either 325 or 350 I can't
remember also typed in my head that it
light intensity being below that and you
can see that in all of those cages it is
below the guide recommendations but
really the but the place you want to be
is in cage see where it's below that top
isolator getting a lot of shade so
thinking about in terms of you know what
does it what does a mouse potentially
one what are what type of lighting
conditions are they exposed to in the
wild so I looked up what it so they're
nocturnal and actually they're
technically crepuscular which means that
they have peaks of activity at dawn and
dusk and so looking at the intensity at
twilight so in that section the bottom
section lux levels are between 1 and 10
at twilight and do
a night at full moon it's at point one
looks and so just thinking about the
lighting conditions in which we house
them even though these are lower than
guide recommendations they're still
really bright compared to where the
environment and mouse might actually be
out being active in and so thinking
about that and how even though we're
doing our best and we still have to go
into these rooms and be able to see that
we are still potentially introducing
some type of stress associated with
these high intensity lighting compared
to where they would spend their time
okay so moving on to social stressors so
here what I'm looking at odor and
auditory cues as well as cage cleaning
so again looking at how goes disrupt
your markings so as far as social orders
smell is the most the very most
important Mouse sense it's like human
vision we utilize that more than any
other sense but to a mouse its smell so
they use it for predator avoidance
there's actually some really cool
studies where they look to see how mice
reacted to cat feces that had been fed
either mice or a much more vegetarian
ish diet and that the mice reacted to
those the smells from both of those
species very differently and showed much
more avoidance behavior and the mice
that had been said mice are the cats
that had been fed mice but they also use
smell for for identifying food for
mating and many many social behaviors
but of course in order to keep our
animals healthy we have to clean their
cages and unfortunately when we do that
would take away their entire sent world
and just replace it with something brand
new and so you often see a lot of
increased aggressive interactions after
introducing them into this new clean
odor free or mouse odor free
environments and as I mentioned a little
earlier the only thing that's really
been shown to reduce aggression is
transferring the nest so apparently this
is some literature that I've been trying
to look into a little bit more is that
in the nest they sent the nest with
their plant our glands which are
supposedly more affiliated form of
pheromones instead of territorial ones
that are urinary based and so when
you're transferring those affiliative
pheromones you don't see this increase
in aggression because if you were to
potentially grab a bit a bedding
material and sprinkle it around the cage
in that new cage thinking that you're
doing a really great job and
transferring that odor environment how
do you know you picked up the the the
urine from the dominant mouse or this
important mouse so your true you
accidentally grabbed that subordinate
Mouse's urine or pheromones and you
sprinkle it around the cage and they get
into the new cage the dominant guys like
hey I thought we had this figured out
and he's like it wasn't me man it wasn't
me um so potentially we're making that
worse by transferring dirty bedding but
by transferring the nest you're
potentially transferring the good
affiliative pheromones so cage cleaning
when we disrupt those odors really
affects behavior and physiology and so
obviously there's important reasons for
why we do that to keep it clean to
reduce ammonia levels and that sort of
thing but it does have an impact on
these animals and for a pretty
substantial amount of time so this was a
really cool study done by Gordon and all
in 2012 where they had implanted
telemetry devices that were monitoring
things like heart rates systolic blood
pressure activity body core temperature
and they looked at just utilizing how
these animals were affected just by
routine procedures and I'm just showing
you the cage change data and so the
little dotted line on each of these
graphs so a B and C is when they mice
were transferred to the clean cage and
you can see that they have sustained
blood pressure for up to a hundred
a hundred minutes post-transfer they
have sustained heart rate issues up to a
hundred minutes and activity levels that
are much higher than base line in these
animals and on top of this they found
that females had much more sustained
changes from their baseline measures
than they did the males so again it's
not even a clear cut everybody reacts
the same so thinking about this in terms
of when you might be planning to do your
procedure whatever that might be testing
the animal in some way knowing where it
falls in accordance to when those
animals might have had their cages
change is really important because if
you're trying to do something right
after you might see some altered
physiological or behavioral responses
just due to cleaning their cage so being
aware of those potential stressors is
really important all right so for our
last section we're going to go into
temperature a little bit and this is an
area that I'm very passionate about and
is a stressor that I think most people
don't realize occurs in a normal typical
laboratory so just to give you a little
background the lower critical
temperature for mice is right around 30
degrees Celsius so this is a temperature
at which the body doesn't have to
utilize much energy to heat or cool
itself the heat loss and key production
are pretty equal but as temperatures get
lower so at our housing recommended
housing temperatures of 20 to 26 degrees
Celsius we see a subsequent increase in
metabolic rate because these animals are
utilizing or losing much more heat and
have to create more heat internally in
order to maintain homeopath or just
below hip housing temperatures we see
reductions in growth organ weight and
even function and increases in basal
metabolic rate so really we are housing
animals and cold conditions even though
it might feel comfortable for us humans
in a lab coat it's actually quite cold
for my simply to do to the physics of
heat
change and it all has to do with the
surface area to volume ratio and that
larger animals like humans don't lose
heat quite as readily where I smaller
animals like mice heat is essentially
just sucked out of them so as far as
some scientific implications of having
cold stress mice in your lab is that
we've seen a lot of really interesting
data especially in the last few years
and how it's affecting it and even
models so we see that there's altered
fever responses of animals housed in
normal laboratory temperatures compared
to something that's closer to 30 degrees
which is their lower critical
temperature and we've seen some
increases in immune suppression so this
was a fabulous study that was done by
catalyst in elizabeth through passkeys
lab and what they did the only
difference in these two groups is that
one group the blue group was housed in
22 degrees Celsius so a typical
laboratory temperature and then the red
group was housed in 30 degrees Celsius
so again that comfortable temperature
for rat or for mice and they found that
tumor volumes in these animals at 20 and
25 days post inoculation was
significantly different and even some
animals didn't even if they saw vast
differences in tumor growth in these two
groups of animals and that's the only
difference some of the animals were held
at a temperature which is comfortable
and some of the animals that were not in
a typical laboratory temperature and so
there's a lot of implications of how
this could be affecting our scientific
models and then when looking at
cardiovascular models we see really
significant alterations in blood
pressure heart rate pulse pressure at
low temperatures so in this graph I have
below you can see that on the x-axis it
has changing ambient temperatures so it
starts off at 30 and where I've got it
stopped it's it's down to a 30 18
degrees Celsius so what temperature's
going down and you can see that that the
beats the heart rate is going up in both
rats and mice
and then as you reduce the temperature
change the temperature so it's going
back to that comfortable temperature
again you see that these measures go
back down so again depending on how what
what your study is and what measures you
might be taking this could be really
influential just simply by the
temperature that you're holding these
animals so increased metabolism is
obviously a repercussion of keeping
these animals and cooler temperatures
and actually this leads to from their
basal metabolic rate to a typical lab
temperatures of about 20 Celsius this
leads to a fifty to sixty percent higher
level of metabolism so they may not
really mean anything to you but when you
think about if you look at the human
literature a mild cold stress for a
human is considered as seven to twelve
percent increase in metabolic rate so
this is these animals are actually
really cold stressed and that's having a
lot of impact on their physiology and
behavior you can see increases in
oxidative stress because they have
increased all of that metabolism you see
a lot of those free radicals associated
with oxidative stress in addition we see
obesity models not even occurring
depending on the temperature that
they're being Houston so in this this
illustration the animals in the blue
bubbles are at room temperature so a
typical laboratory temperature 2222 and
there you see pea protein knockout mice
which is really involved with brown fats
heat production and so in the knockout
mice when there are normal temperatures
they don't become obese but if you put
them in that 30 degrees Celsius you
start these animals to become obese
later developing edit and so it's just
it's quite crazy that this is something
that people don't often think about for
their animals so there's been some
discussion lately in the thermal
metabolic world about well what should
we do about this and a lot of people are
calling for change in laboratory
temperatures to warmer temperatures
closer to
30 degrees but in my opinion I don't
think thermo neutrality is actually the
answer so I've done a lot of preference
work looking at what temperatures mice
actually want and we did this study with
black six mice overall they prefer 30
degrees Celsius and this is especially
important for when they're inactive so
you can see in these purple bars they
spend significantly more time in the 30
C than they do in the 20 see but we
found that this their preference changes
throughout the day in one one particular
animal and so there's differences
between sexes time of day the behavior
as well as the age of the animal and so
just to further illustrate this when
we're looking simply at active behavior
animals are just locomotive running
around sniffing digging in the betting
that sort of thing they show absolutely
no preference for a certain temperature
when they're doing this particular type
of behavior and so thinking about it you
can we as humans can't identify a
perfect temperature for even one animal
and so I think it's kind of very
humanistic above us to think that we can
find a perfect temperature but on top of
this if we were to increase temperatures
we see subsequent increases in
aggression just based on temperature and
so if this is already an issue were
encountering and laboratory mice we
don't want to exacerbate it and so by
increasing the temperature we may have
more animal losses simply due to general
aggression and you also see a reduction
in reproduction when temperatures are
greater than 25 c which is 78 degrees
fahrenheit so that just right at the
very upper limits of what's recommended
by the guide and so if you go above that
to thermo neutrality you actually will
find a reduction overall reproduction if
you are breeding and your colony so in
my opinion changing laboratory
temperatures to thermo neutrality is not
the answer so you might be saying okay
Briana so what is the answer then well I
am going to explain what i'm going to
show you here in a sec
because I can't talk during the video
but what I'm going to be showing you is
how insulating nests can be and so
giving the animals the opportunity to
create their own microclimate and so
what you're going to see in this video
is there's going to be a little cursor
the jet surrounds and I think it's the
dark blue cursor in the middle of the
screen and it will tell you what that
temperature is down at the bottom in the
pink number so right now it's saying
that it's 30.7 degrees Celsius and so
it's going to jump around and at the end
of the video we'll talk about what it is
that it stops at so if someone could
play the video for me
you
so so as you saw in the video the cursor
stopped in the middle of the nest once
the mouse had been shoot out the
temperature was 32.5 degrees celsius
know one of the things i didn't tell you
is that the yellow number at the top of
the screen the 21.3 is the ambient
temperature that it's measuring and so
that nest is almost is over 10 degrees
Celsius higher than the ambient
temperature that the animals being
houston so they can really heat up these
nests and it was measured several
seconds after the nest had been opened
and so he was readily dissipating as
soon as that nest was opened and so it's
possible that the the internal
temperature inside that nest might have
been even a little bit warmer so nest
can be extremely insulating and so we've
done a lot of work looking at what are
the benefits of providing the rights
environmental enrichment in the right
nesting material for mice and what we
found is that mice meet at least 28
grams 8 to 10 grams of nesting material
and what we found is that females may
actually need more than 10 grams in
order to properly insulate they seem to
be more susceptible to the same
temperatures than the males do and that
may be a product simply because they're
just a little bit smaller than the males
we see reductions in food consumption
when they are provided with a nesting
material reduction in physiological
thermogenesis reductions in pup
mortality as well as more pups produced
per cage and so that's actually the
image that i'm showing you over to the
right and we've got provision of enviro
dry or nests lips and i will say it was
equal amounts so we gave them eight
grams of enviro and eight grams of
netflix which is actually three
nestlings and that is very uncommon for
people to utilize and so we found that
regardless of the type of enrichment you
give them if you give them enough
nesting material they have significantly
more pups than controls that don't have
any nesting material and this really
translates in the breeding life of an
animal of ten to twelve and a half more
puffs on average per cage now that's
averaged over several streams but
ultimately you get more pups from the
same animals and so going through some
of these other slides here quickly the
benefits of giving the right enrichment
and the right type of nesting material
this is a study that I conducted with
some colleagues at Charles River we were
implement we were mimicking a tox
environment a talked study where we were
injecting animals with cyclophosphamide
which is an immune modulating drug it's
often utilized in chemotherapies and
it's a pretty well studied item in the
talks illogical field and so what we did
is we injected these animals with
cyclophosphamide once a week for 13
weeks and what we did is we collected
equal pallets to determine overall
corticosterone levels and so this graph
is actually showing you the difference
from their baseline before the study
started so 0 equals baseline so if the
bar is above it and means that their
level of hormones was more than when
they started and if it's under it means
that it's reduced below baseline and so
what we found is that animals that were
given saline so we had two sites alien
controls in this study as well that
controls actually had significantly
higher levels of corticosterone
metabolites even when they weren't given
nesting materials so basically what that
saying is that that gray bar and a Salem
side is significantly higher than zero
but when the mice were given nesting
material it really showed no difference
but the really important result that we
found is that the animals that were
provided with cyclophosphamide had a
significant increase in stress
metabolites found in their feces when
they did not have any nesting material
and actually the animals again did that
God psyche with Fossum I'd but had a
nest had almost exact levels of the
baseline before they even started so
these animals even though they were
given this drug that's supposed to make
them not necessarily feel very well
their stress levels were so much lower
and in the same study reset we found
that mice with nesting material actually
had higher relative % b lymphocytes
compared to controls now this is
averaged over whether they got
cyclophosphamide or not so this was a
really great results showing that these
animals are adapting to potential stress
so everyone got injections but that the
animals that were provided with enough
nesting material we gave them 10 grams
of nesting material in this study that
they seemed to adapt to these stressors
much better so you may be thinking okay
Briana so you know mice experience a lot
of stress in the wild you know they it
gets really cold sometimes rude they
can't find food and actually one of my
favorite anecdotes is that mice had been
documented to live and breed and meet
freezers so this is negative 40 degrees
Celsius however in the laboratory they
will become hypothermic within 12 to 26
minutes at about the same temperature so
the question becomes why is it one can
flourish in essentially a temperature
anyone cans well really if we think
about it animals exists to behave and
they use behavior in order to control
the environment so even though it's a
stressor it really it depends on the
animals ability to feel like they can
control that stressor and create let's
say a small microclimate a nice warm
nest inside of a meat freezer and they
can stay long so really behavior gives
animals the ability to control or even
their perception of controlling
stressors and this was very well
illustrated by a fabulous researcher
named vice in 1970 and what he found was
that rats who were subjected to an
electric shock animals that were given
an indicator like a little likes as to
when the shock was going to occur they
did not show the same stress responses
as did the animals that exceed received
the same intensity and duration of the
shock so the wraps on the left that
didn't get the indicator they had ulcers
and some of those animals died whereas
these other animals on the right that
had the cue the children when it was
coming did not have any of those
physiological alterations so in
conclusion and I realize I've gone
really long because I'm really excited
about telling everyone about this that
the lab environment is not very well
designed for animals that live within it
and that ultimately stress is inevitable
but when you think about your animals
try and figure out how you can give them
the tools to control the stressors
around them so that they can build
different types of enrichments and
shelter themselves from those stressors
and really the right environmental
enrichment can can help with that and so
don't worry about the stressors if you
give the animals the tools to control
them and with that I will take questions
I know I've gone long but I'm happy to
answer any that anybody might have thank
you doctor gasps go for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A so if you
have a question you'd like to ask dr.
gaskill please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click on the send button
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is from suzette at
novartis institutes for biomedical
research and she asks is there data of
this nature for induced stress
activators for dogs and monkeys I'm
guessing you're asking if it's the same
environmental stressors and there is
some research especially in non-human
primates that does show that there are I
think specifically a lack of retreat
space those animals do show increased
stress responses I'm not familiar with
much of the dog research so I don't feel
like I can answer that but i think the
research does exist it's just sometimes
very hard to find and it's it's fairly
limited overall but there are there is
literature in non-human primates I do
you know that as far as environmental
stressors
hey Jeff from ukcs asks about nesting
material is that eight to ten grams per
mouse or per box for what excellent
question i'm really glad somebody asked
that so in this particular study it was
eight to ten grams for three mice and so
as you may have larger cages and more
animals you start to see a trade off so
now you have more bodies in a cage so
they can huddle better and conserve more
heat but at the same time the mass gets
bigger and so you might need more
material to potentially cover the entire
group of animals so I would say at least
within typical caging where you might
have up to four to five mice I would
think that right around ten would
probably be okay but unfortunately we
haven't done the research to look at you
know how does that trade off as you add
more animals can you you know are they
as cold or are they able to huddle and
conserve more heat through that so that
I can't really specifically address we
haven't done that research yet but the
eight to ten grams was for three mice in
a cage Hank from metris metris asks
getting back to the ultrasound noise
have you used a sound attenuation
chamber in your studies if so which one
and if not which one would you consider
using in your research so unfortunately
I haven't done a ton of ultrasound
research and trying to figure out how to
reduce the amount of ultrasound within a
vivarium so I can't really give you any
recommendations as far as attenuating
structures but one of the really best
ways to do it is to go buy a cheap and
easy
a bat detector and you can walk around
to different things within the
environment up to the lights around the
computer monitors around the computer
and identify where that ultrasound is
coming from because the bat detector
will take that ultrasound down to levels
that you can hear so you can identify
where the ultrasound is coming from to
try and reduce it the thing that's
really cool about ultrasound is thinking
about it in terms of line of sight so if
ultrasound is coming this way if you
just put up a physical block like this
it actually won't pass through because
it's so high frequency those wait those
sounds just doesn't travel very well and
so all you'd have to do is just set up a
block so some people use like a
plexiglass almost like a divider and you
don't necessarily have to put it on your
computer where the sound is coming out
but just put it a little bit away so
obviously the fan and whatever can still
ventilate within the computer but it
will stop the ultrasound transmitting
across the room so just identifying
whether where it's coming from is
probably the first step of eliminating
it we are out of time I would like to
once again thank dr. Briana Gaskell for
her presentation do you have any final
comments for us today well I think I've
commented a lot since I went over time
and I appreciate everybody who stuck in
there but just start thinking about
thinking about your species that you're
working with and how they may be
perceiving the environment around them
and how that may be creating some stress
and how you can take some steps to
attempt to alleviate it or provide them
with the tools that they can control it
thanks again I would also like to thank
our sponsor leverage for making today's
educational webcast possible this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
race continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your CD
credits click on the CD button located
in the bottom left-hand corner
your web page before we go and let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August fourth 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
me know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues sort
of miss today's live event that's all
for now thanks for joining us